Cows and livestock are
major contributors to carbon emissions.
But now some scientists are saying
not so fast
and arguing
cows, in fact,
can actually be part of the solution.
According to the Food and Agriculture
Organization, livestock
farming accounts for more than 14%
of manmade emissions.
Researchers, however, say
if farmers change the way
their cows graze,
it could make a drastic difference.
CNN's chief
climate correspondent Bill Weir is here.
And Bill, what needs to happen?
Well, these guys would say
farmers need to get fall back in love
with Mother Nature and be closer to her
than their fertilizer salesmen.
This is basically a style of farming
that was common
across humanity up until World War Two.
But it's really about letting nature
do the work and taking influence
from some very powerful models.
In the beginning, was the buffalo,
tens of millions of them
wandering the land, munching wild grasses
and using poop and hooves to create rich,
fertile soil up to 15 feet deep.
Look at this.
But since Americans replaced buffalo
with cows,
generations of fertilizers
and pesticides,
tilling and overgrazing
have turned much of that nutrient
rich soil into lifeless dirt,
but not on farms where they graze cows,
just like wild buffalo.
Well,
so adaptive multi paddock
grazing and grazing
is a way that mimics
the way bison
have moved across the Great Plains.
And so it's really about the animals
hit an area really hard
and then they leave it for a long time.
Peter Bick is a professor
at Arizona State University,
and he believes that
if enough
beef and dairy operations
copy this simple hack,
cattle could actually become an ally
in the fight against climate change.
I anticipate we'll get a lot of pushback
because
people are
not thinking
that cows can be a part of the solution.
Not only are you going
against the grain of environmentalists
who think meat is evil
for lots of reasons.
You took money from McDonald's for this?
Yeah,
I asked for money for McDonald's
for this.
I wanted to go to big companies
because if they don't change,
we don't get there.
For his docu series Roots.
So Deep,
you can see the devil down there.
Big assembled a team of scientists.
We're really interested in insects
that live in poop
experts and bugs and birds
Yes.
Bad boy, cows, soils and carbon.
They spent
years comparing five
sets of neighboring farms
in the southeast.
On one side,
traditional grazers
who let cows roam
one big field for months at a time
and often cut fertilized grass for
hay would come off.
On the other side,
amp grazers who never mow or fertilize
you open a gate they go through.
It takes 5 minutes to roll up a wire
and with a single line
of electrical fence, move
their cows from one patch of high
grass to the next
not smell them fat.
This is how easy it is thator.
While their science is yet
to be published and peer reviewed.
Big says early data has found AMP Farms
pulling down up to four times the carbon
while holding 25% more microbes
three times the bird life and twice
as much rain per hour.
If it's a thousand
acre farm it's 54 million
gallons of water
that's now washing your soil away
versus soaking into your land.
Wow, look at this grass.
But this is also a human experiment
to see
whether data and respectful discussion
can change hearts and minds.
This was crazy about 40 days ago,
and this hadn't been fertilized
in 12 years. Larson.
And when we got out of spending money
on fertilizer, it was huge, huge.
And I don't think that ever happened.
It is such a stress release.
We just don't worry
about a lot of it anymore.
And you
don't even fertilize
when you point your rag, right? Awesome.
It sounds crazy,
but it's letting Mother Nature
do the work.
Would it be an interesting thing
if you didn't have to pay for fertilizer?
Would that be one of them?
Curtis Spangler
is one of the conventional farmers
in Route So Deep,
and he says his mind was changed
when he realized
he now has a way to double his herd
and quit his second off farm job.
Right now,
We're having to dump thousands of dollars
in the nitrogen every year
that really
if we just change a couple of things,
we might be able to save that money
to put it toward other
resources.
Is that something you're committed
to doing now as a result of this project?
Yeah,
we're really looking
and seeing the benefits of it
and how we can work it.
So as we hit the height
of grilling season
a little food for thought,
there is ways to produce meat
that is not good for the planet,
and there's ways to produce meat
that's really good for the planet.
And that's the nuance that's been missing
My little boy has a farm puzzle,
you know, with the one pig and one count,
the one chicken in this idyllic scene.
And we don't realize that
that is so far from what we have now.
It's either big farms that are massive
or they go out of business, or we do.
But we've embraced mass production.
I mean,
does this affect
kind of our ability to kind of provide
the nation agriculturally?
They would say it absolutely does.
The grass could replace feedlots
if as a as a disruptor,
a cheaper alternative.
But going against
these ideas is a massive big ag industry,
fertilizers, big machinery, all of that,
because all of the solutions are natural.
Do they have a plan to scale?
Well, this is early.
This is just like let's
see if we can convince farmers
across the fence to talk to each other.
And that's
what's so heartwarming about this series.
You've got
two of the pairs
actually are two founding members
of the country band Alabama
Randy Owen is a traditional grazier,
Teddy Gentry.
He's been an app farmer
his whole life and comparing
and they don't talk to each other
about it.
You know,
these are proud folks who work the land
and don't really discuss there.
But this is really an interesting
look at breaking common ground.
Could be a solution for everybody.
Healthier cows, land
birds, people, farmers, bottom lines
by learning
about the culture of the spill. We're.
Thank you. My pleasure.